this has been a labor of love gets me
yeah it's it's been the the best and
worst relationship I've ever been in 11
years have been trying to get this movie
made and and you you know we we we wrote
a suite of script we did that about six
years ago to meet a little bit of test
footage for this movie that test footage
sat on a shelf at Fox for four years and
then about a year and a half ago
somebody accidentally leaked it on the
Internet super crazy just when people
just started writing at flooding Fox
with begging and pleading for them for
the Deadpool movie to get made and
within 24 hours we had a green light
we're making it we're so yeah is that
quick it was that quick they just it was
so undeniable and it was a group felt
felt really good but also you must be
quite pissed off that you know what you
couldn't make the decision for yourself
exactly we tried we tried and try try
but the fans got it made so there's a
great story to that this is the totally
fan driven it people who don't know that
they'll be thinking why why wouldn't the
studio want to make this movie it's a
superhero movie everyone loves that and
it is a mirror movie and it's got all
those things but it does also have this
kind of indie movie Sensibility yeah
well it's it's meta I mean the character
knows he's in a comic book movie but he
works in the x-men universe so he's
dealing with other x-men he's talking
about other x-men he's be making jokes
about Ryan Reynolds I mean it's very you
know it's rated R which is unusual for
you know Marvel x-men type movie it I
think it's certificate 15 here and in
the UK we can invent get yes in China
it's rated go [ __ ] yourself
I wish they could show their but yeah so
it's it's it's a pretty unorthodox film
and also what's great is to reflect like
that that poster but also you've done
other posters oh man the marketing of
this movie has been so much fun it's
like you involved in all things
completely we love it we're like giddy
lis texting and emailing each other in
the middle of the night like what if we
tried this the emoji poster I love the
emoji booster that's pretty great
Deadpool message between me and a couple
of the people and then the Fox marina
guess we're gonna make that the
Billboard said you don't have a balls to
me you haven't forgotten that it's
opening Valentine's weekend of course
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
there's a romantic love story in the
film and then I mean the love story
quickly turns into dick kicking revenge
shocked me that you because in American
TV you can't say stuff like that no you
can't say
I'll be saying hi on the couch
and also like you say you didn't just
work on the things you did the
voiceovers for some of the trailers you
did yeah I did yeah yeah yeah exactly
yeah I love that stuff so I do it at
home all the time Pres my wife not since
then you know it's that voice that in
world / fear Will Smith
Ryan Reynolds Catherine zeta-jones Dobby
Joe Graham Norton's pants rated on no
but the cheers up when you started kind
of being interested in girls you weren't
as that cool or smooth with it no no no
no no I really I went through puberty at
like 27 school the first the first girl
first walk I was obsessed with this this
girl Fiona Gore chin ski mmm yeah she
actually she used to take the bus the
the the opposite way of my actual home
and I would get on the bus just to sit
next to her for 45 minutes the wrong way
there's something wonderful about
something water yeah
I love it when you're young it's so cute
when you're older it's just stalking
some kind of watchlist I've been more
than I don't know 11 years old and I was
just about to get off the bus cuz enough
is enough I'm about to enter like
Seattle or something so I've certainly
got the bus and I decided like kind of
hit her with like this cool look or
something like this like one of these
like really sort of Don Johnson might
like and I sort of delay a little too
long and the bus doors close on my back
and the bus just starts to leave the
door let's release his mic you know I
could never look at her again yeah she's
looking at you now he's the guy with the
backpack
the idiot with the ren and stimpy back
right we don't think of Canadians as
having accents and yet usually do
you've lost your accent you would say
yeah I sort of trained myself out of it
but you know I go back home and it pops
up again it's oh yeah it's a cat it's a
boat and that's not saying hey the way
you say you talk about a boat but it's
all my everything is I it's a bad word
but I'm sorry so you handle everything
with off fuck-buddy and they said
something about the Canadian accent that
makes you a really bad liar
yeah well it's the yeah we're not we're
not good at lying or fighting really
where did you go to the border trying oh
yeah yeah I was I went my wife is a
foodie she loves these apple pies that
they make at this at this place in
Vancouver where I grew up so we grabbed
a bunch of them and headed we're driving
back down to the States and we're across
the border you don't a little cross the
border with and this guy knew something
was going on and we get up to the border
crossing like a kilo of cocaine you know
but he was going on a worst poker face
that where spy faces yeah and he says uh
was my voice gets really high when I'm
when I'm like lying because like he got
anything any fruit any vegetables in
that guy was like basically agent had
the other hook he looks at me he goes
hey I remember that you know movie he
did that movie just friends and I was
like yeah yeah yeah it was like your
that song at the end of it were you
seeing this I swear by all for one it's
like yeah he's like yeah go ahead dance
monkey dance
in the best balls
[Laughter]
[Music]
you